I might do
Laban talking to you from the University
in Jerusalem I want to thank the
organizer of this birthday celebration
for having invited me to be one of the
speakers in honor of tea cup dyrdek it's
your 80th birthday and I want to tell
you that becoming a tea is not the end
it's not even the beginning of the end
it's only the end of the beginning and
you and we all have many happy and
active ears and of us they can I we have
many years together going all the way
back to the 1960s the IBM where we first
met and we had many unbelievably
interesting conversations both about
computer science and general subjects
together so it is really very happy
moment for me not to see you directly
but to be via the Internet to be with
you here again my lecture today is going
to cover some of our joint work and
later on some of my own later work that
was done which I am going to describe
just as proof that even after 80 you are
of course extremely active and so am I
so in nineteen eighty i was visiting
berkeley and it came across the problem
came across the problem of of string
matching and three galil
had a new algorithm for string matching
which had used the number of required a
registers from about n for pattern of
length n to a fixed number of registers
I thought that there should be a an
efficient and simple and my solution for
that new result and so I had a certain
solution and I came and told you dick
about it you immediately had an
important simplification and we went on
to write the paper that appeared in 90
in 1987 in which people tell me became a
classic so let me briefly describe the
problem namely sufficient randomized
string matching algorithm not even one
but actually a family of algorithms so
you have a string X a1 a2 x a1 a2 up to
a n of symbols for example zeros and
ones and that's one example of a pattern
and you have another much longer string
yb-1 up to be M which is the text and
the question is well in the text does
the pattern appeal so here is a small
mini example you have a BB a there is no
match here no match here no material but
finally there is a match so the exercise
is to find all in this is K such that X
the bottom matches the KF stretch of n
symbols in the text now this problem had
already a long history the first
important sult is you not surprisingly
to close closed mouths but in 1977 just
one example of the many outstanding and
nice results due to our friend Ruth and
they gave a solution that required oh
and registers for fast implementation as
I mentioned before in 1980 in Berkeley
Gallaudet's I first found a solution
published in nineteen eighty one which
require just a constant number of
registers this was a deterministic
solution and involved a complex
algorithm in 1978 in England Baker
channel has the determines deterministic
string matching to general arrays
multi-dimensional arrays so for example
you can look for a pattern which is a
rectangle of A's and B's in the text
which is a larger rectangle of A's and
B's and similarly for higher dimensions
Fishkin in 1985 gave our level for this
deterministic algorithms so now I come
to the car payment historical solution
for that problem you choose a hand of
Prime in the range between one and then
end
times M square that means if you think
about it for a moment that this is
actually rather small pine now we
consider in this example the x and y to
be a text a pattern and text consisting
of zeros and ones the AI and the BIR
evil 0 or 1 we start by computing a
which is the bottom mod p in other words
number smaller than p and we take the
first search of n bits in the text and
we also consider and compute and
consider its residue mod p now if a
equals a 1 there is a match in location
one with high probability of e being
right now we test the location namely
the text in this way using using mod p
residues bit by bit the an important
feature is that the update of the
fingerprint so-called of the earth
stretch of n bits in the text can be
updated from AI to AI plus 1 very easily
as seen in the first two lines of the
slide show now now if in fact there is a
match then of course there is going to
be agreement
of the ring finger prints however at the
same time if the fingerprints agree
there is a match with very high
probability we call this methodology
fingerprinting now continuing the
description of capillary an algorithm
it's very efficient updates one module
multiplication to module additions /
update one move forward within the text
it needs five only five registers for
holding locations and prime in memory
quickness I've already quickness I've
already described before cap 11 easily
naturally yields all previous results
and in many instances even improved
forms of those results many string
ecology results are uniformly and easily
solved by the kale fingerprinting method
in 1981 I introduced fingerprinted using
irreducible polynomials which is widely
used also for many security problems now
as I said in my introduction becoming a
tea is not the end of one's life and
career I want to say about the previous
welcome off with the cup that all of
life's problems should have such elegant
and easy solutions coming now to new
results I said in my introduction that
we coming 80s lows the
and the cap is amply proved it by his
work in recent years I want to describe
some of my own work and work with others
in the same vein of being able to
innovate even at what is considered
quote advanced age and quad so this is
efficient zero-knowledge spoofs and the
Welcome going to the scribe goes back to
the papers Alice T 2007 RM my 2012
that's when these papers appeared in
print and then i'm going to give another
important application due to sylvia
McCallion myself so the basic concept is
random split value representations of
values a value X in the range 0 to B
minus 1 which is the finite field zpp
ism is actually a small quote unquote
prime let's say at most two to the 128
in other words fitting into one or two
computer worlds and we our operations
are addition and multiplication mod p
now suppose we have a value X and we
represented random split value
representation by a vector by a random
vector capital X UV and the value of
that vector is going to be u plus V mod
p which should be lower case X how do we
construct that random representation we
choose the first coordinate you randomly
from in the fields EP and then we take
the other Calder V as X minus you must
be so obviously you plus we must be is X
now note that each coordinate by itself
is completely random and if he wheeled
on its own gives us no information about
the value X in question because of the
complete randomness of you on the one
hand and V by itself on the other end
and Michael Gabe its 11th commandment is
that in this split your presentation you
never revealed both coordinates always
he will at most one either the left or
the right called in it now we use any
kind of commitment function for values
and thus will value commitment to the
vector capital X is the commitment to
the value u comma commitment to the
value V and those commitments are used
later on immediately will be used in the
zero knowledge spoofs so now it is in
fact demonstrated in the papers i
squatted before the television 0 nalds
proofs for the following if Hoover has
split value and as posted split value
commitments to xfit value commitment to
whites with value commitment to Z and
these are posted for verifier the power
can efficiently very efficiently prove
its absolute zero knowledge such
statements that the value of x plus the
value of y is equal to the value
of Z or in another case that the value
of x times the value of y equals the
value of Z all in yet another case that
the value of x is smaller than the value
of y now having the power of similar
spoofs that i described in the previous
slide we want to generalize this to
general straight line computations
acronym gsl see generalized straight
line computations so we can assume a
very general situation where the input
values from x 1 up to xn lowercase X 1
up to Locust xn from players which could
be bad also could be something else p 1
up to be n now in evaluate approval k
it's a generalized straight line
computation which has outputs and
explore case L a function of the inputs
up to XL plus 1 a function f l plus one
of those inputs for example the outputs
could be the ordering the ordering of
these inputs so he looks at the inputs
and EK it's the general a straight line
computation for other problems also so
that's all m greater than n there is two
previous indices I and J such that X M
is either sum of X I and XJ mod p or the
part of these two or XM is the two
both value of the relationship exile s 0
equal to XJ other operations more
general operations are also treatable
the g SL see in question of course is
adopted always made to solve the problem
which has to be solved and we are going
to have examples in the in the following
now the approach suggested and developed
in the papers mentioned deal well
directly with small as it use mod p
there is no need even for solving
problems like proving x smaller than y
to go down to the bit value there is no
need as some solutions to problems about
for example auctions you are to use home
roving heavy home harvick encryptions
with very large number in general the
evaluative hoover gets a straight line
computation appropriate for the problem
or task at hand then extends it by
additional lines to create a total poof
of the coldness of the output results
and posts split value commitments to all
values in question except for the output
values and post those on let's say a
public bulletin board using that public
bulletin board anybody can verify the
correctness
of the outputs as a function of the
still hidden completely hidden inputs
and intermediate computations in other
words the computations or perceiving the
index L in the previous slide these
zeros proofs are very natural convincing
and very very tight so one application
is to secure auctions we use the above
techniques to concert auctions such that
for any auction the auction announces
and proofs correctness of the results
without revealing bit values there are
many important auctions where the
participants the bidders do still even
at the end want their bid to remain
secret and you can easily think about
valid reasons and important reasons for
that desire not to have bid values
especially in repeated auctions revealed
to thee to the other bidders auto the
world now for victory auctions Vic any
actions which are second pies auctions
and I'll well known to be very porn to
collusion between the bidders against
the auctioneer of the seller that was an
open problem for many years and because
of that possibility of collusion these
auctions despite their important
theoretical poverty's will not used in
practice now in 2011-2012
and in a paper in 2014 McCauley and I
solved that problem by showing that
using these efficient 0 nalds proofs we
can create VK auction second pass
auctions where collusion is probably
avoided now another application of that
methodology was suggested to me by
reverse bell on the west and together we
then did system of electronic voting we
used sweet value of the presentations
and zero knowledge poofs to construct
voting systems such that the rotor
privacy is provably preserved in other
words whatever anyone voted this kept
probably kept secret the telling of the
vols produces outcome verifiable by
everyone so that if the bottom line is
that I'll go 11 the election then that
can be actually proved in a completely
convincing way without revealing any
private values of vaults so my voting
system with the andheri west has the
properties i mentioned above and in
addition system correctness namely the
system is immune against any prescribed
numbers say for of gossipy and all
failing vault counters the gossipy
fourth counters who see the votes but
actually only components of the votes
not even if for fuel of them could get
together they cannot reveal the vote of
any particular of water let me add the
bullet not present on this slide that
also all the incorrect votes for example
if somebody gave two votes or five votes
to one of the candidates all of these
are removable in our election electronic
voting system use elsewhere Linda Linda
Eva and here is evidence to the paper
that appeared at the very important
conference you split value
representations and the vision and the
connected efficient general spoofs to
achieve highly efficient multi-party
computations we are inviting further
applications of this method we are sure
that many other applications exist and
many people can follow the lindell eva
footsteps and gain wonderful results
obtained wonderful results using this
new methodology so thank you all and
then particular dick come and see you
all at the 90th birthday celebration 10
years from now by